Harold you stay put I'll come back for
you when it's safe out of my way creep
or you are oh hey Saginaw its fans I am
Scott here with Matt we're gonna talk to
you a little bit about rhombus of ruin
which is a PlayStation VR exclusive from
Double Fine and tim schafer it's
actually coming out later this month
februari 21st so be sure to subscribe to
catch our review from what we know so
far it's supposed to sort of bridge the
story gap between the original
psychonauts and the upcoming Psychonauts
2 so Matt I'm curious he was like what
portion of the game were you allowed to
play how much did you actually see just
give us a sense of what you got to play
in the demo so I saw the airplane
sequence where you play as Raz and
you're sort of discovering how to
traverse to the environment which
involves his clairvoyance ability you
will use it in order to sort of possess
other people in the environment and as
you're possessing other people you see
from obvious different perspectives
within the environment and you can find
these different things to interact with
oh cool so that's actually ties into the
main sort of gameplay mechanics in it
which is very puzzled driven okay cool
so can you give us a sense of like how a
puzzle plays out in rumson brood so the
main goal right is you're trying to find
lily I cared from the first first game
trying to find her her father what's
that light up there could be one of the
others and so I got to zap into where he
is and the main objective in this
scenario was I had to find out where he
was in terms of like the environment so
use my clairvoyance ability to possess
him and then try to possess other people
in the environment for example like I'd
find this low light gadget that
basically looked like a toy right well
psychonauts yeah exactly like little
child's toy so you and the whole thing's
like I pressed the button and it
revealed this window and it revealed
like oh wait we're underwater but where
are we under water gotcha should get
like little bits and clues as you saw a
puzzle exactly this kind of sounds a bit
like an adventure game actually which is
which is weird because the original
psychonauts was obviously more of a
platformer did it feel like an adventure
game it totally did um it was
interesting cuz the woodway that Tim
Schaefer had put it when I talked to him
is that he called a kind of a a gaze and
click right said of a point-and-click
eggs hey look at stuff and click I
thought that makes sense it
certainly sounds like that's how it
played out yeah so overall how did you
feel about what you played like did you
actually enjoy it yeah I liked it a lot
I think my one concern was that it was a
bit too straightforward i mean the
puzzles you know they were there and it
kind of took me a little while to figure
some of them out but they weren't really
that complex it just kind of involved
like all right let me just poke around
here enough times and see what happens
gotcha okay and I guess the game is only
supposed to be about three hours or so I
mean hopefully it'll get a little more
complex and interesting over the course
of that three hours but that is that's
pretty short so who knows but we'll find
out soon enough either way the game is
out on februari 21st so like I said be
sure to subscribe to check out a review
when that happens you can also head to
the site to check out Matt's written
interview with Tim Schafer along with a
bunch of neo guides coverage of for on
or writing zeroed on lots of good stuff
so yeah like subscribe and stay tuned to
gamespot com for more coverage of
everything video games and psych odds
yes that's it
[Music]
you